[Música]
luto en el mundo del fútbol a los 82
años falleció Edson arantes donas
cimento Pelé en un hospital de la ciudad
de Sao Paulo tras más de un mes de haber
sido hospitalizado futbolistas amigos y
jefes de estado rinden tributo al rey
del fútbol
la Corte Suprema de Perú rechazó la
apelación de la defensa de Pedro
Castillo contra los 18 meses de prisión
preventiva el tribunal impuso también el
impedimento de salida del país por 18
meses Álex Primer Ministro Aníbal Torres
Tenemos reporte desde Lima
abrió el primer dispensario legal de
marihuana en el estado de Nueva York lo
hizo más de un año después de que el
estado legalizara esta droga y en medio
de los retrasos en la creación del
mercado legal para beneficiar a las
personas detenidas anteriormente por
delitos relacionados con la marihuana
bienvenidos al nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este informativo
con la noticia del fallecimiento del rey
del fútbol a sus 82 años el brasileño
Edson arantes Don nacimiento más
conocido como Pelé falleció en un
hospital de Sao Paulo en donde Llevaba
más de un mes ingresado por
complicaciones derivadas de un cáncer de
colon de origen humilde Pelé deslumbró
desde temprano al mundo del fútbol y
consiguió ganar en tres ocasiones el
mundial con Brasil en 1958
1962 y 1970 el presidente Jair bolsonaro
decretó tres días de luto Nacional los
ciudadanos brasileños lloran ahora la
muerte del que fue una leyenda en todo
Brasil y especialmente en Santos la
ciudad que lo vio crecer Alba Santana
tiene los detalles
abrazos hay lágrimas y caras largas para
despedir a uno de los grandes del fútbol
Pelé conocido como El rey el brasileño
murió este jueves a los 82 años dejando
un vacío para muchos para mí el fútbol
está de luto tuvimos nuestra derrota
cuando Brasil perdió en el mundial y
ahora tenemos la noticia de la muerte de
Nuestro Rey Pelé estoy muy triste pero
Pelé es historia una leyenda una
tristeza que llegó también hasta la
playa de Copacabana en Río de Janeiro
donde sus fanáticos decidieron rendirle
honor de la mejor manera posible jugando
al fútbol
vi el Mundial de 1970 cuando era joven
tenía 18 años lo vi y celebré sus
jugadas el jugador más grande que he
visto Pelé es inmortal como el título de
su película Pelé es inmortal
espectacular
la noticia llegó hasta altamara donde
los brasileños de un crucero con destino
a Santos ciudad donde creció Pelé
también lloraron su muerte allí el lunes
celebrará su velorio
es un día muy triste subí al barco con
la camiseta blanca y negra del Santos
Hoy llegué aquí Me puse la camiseta Y me
sorprendió Esta triste noticia
es justo en Santos a su casa quizás
donde el futbolista será más recordado
allí y en todo el país los brasileños
tendrán tres días de luto Nacional para
sobrellevar la tristeza y conmemorar al
eterno astro
las reacciones también llegaron por
parte de diferentes jefes de estado
alrededor del mundo electo presidente de
Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva en un
mensaje en su perfil de Twitter
describió a Pelé como un jugador y un
brasileño que llevó el nombre del país
en alto
Belén nos dejó hoy se fue a compartir
mesa en el cielo con coutinho su gran
Compañero en el Santos ahora está en
compañía de muchas estrellas eternas
Didi garrincha niton Santos Sócrates
Maradona dejó una certeza nunca ha
habido un 10 como él Gracias Pelé
brevemente hablamos con nuestra
corresponsal en Brasil Valeria sakone
quien nos contó Cómo y cuándo se
llevarán a cabo el funeral y el entierro
del astro brasilero
si va a ser todo a partir del dos de
enero la familia ha dicho que necesitaba
de tiempo para organizar todo y para
reunir a la familia toda hay que
recordar que el 1 de enero es la
investidura de Lula y también imagino
que la familia habrá querido no hacer
coincidir los dos actos el dos en la
sede de santos en Vila belmiro habrá un
velorio público desde las 10 de la
mañana
las personas podrán acudir a ver el
ataúd cerrado de Pelé luego al día
siguiente el día 3 habrá una especie de
procesión por toda la ciudad en honor
tanto a Pelé como a su madre dona
Celeste que cumplió seis años el día que
comenzó el mundial en Qatar finalmente
él será enterrado en una ceremonia
solamente reservada para los familiares
y seguimos en Brasil porque Marina Silva
una de las más férreas defensoras de la
amazonía será la nueva ministra de medio
ambiente en el país días antes de su
posesión el primero de enero Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva completó su
gabinete con al menos 16 nuevos
nombramientos Silva repite a la cabeza
de un ministerio que lideró ya entre
2003 y 2010 también durante el gobierno
de Lula sus políticas hicieron que la
deforestación en la amazonía brasileña
se disminuyera como nunca antes también
se conoció que el senador Carlos favaro
será el ministro de agricultura y que
Sonia guajahara liderará la cartera de
pueblos indígenas
quiero desearles buena suerte Que Dios
los bendiga a todos y cada uno de
ustedes por favor sean lo más
democráticos que puedan cuando
establezcan su gobierno es importante
para nosotros Buscar personas con
competencia técnica importantes
estoy convencido de que Tenemos que
montar los mejores ministerios que que
podamos para que todo el mundo pueda
empezar a trabajar
Nos vamos ahora hasta Perú la Corte
Suprema del país rechazó este jueves la
apelación de la defensa de Pedro
Castillo contra los 18 meses de prisión
preventiva que cumple desde el pasado 15
de diciembre el tribunal impuso también
el impedimento de salida del país por 18
meses al ex Primer Ministro Aníbal
Torres nuestro corresponsal en Lima
Francisco Zacarías con todos los
detalles
la justicia peruana ratificó la prisión
preventiva de 18 meses contra el
expresidente Pedro Castillo mientras es
investigado por la fiscalía de este país
por los delitos de rebelión conspiración
abuso autoridad y grave perturbación de
la tranquilidad pública por los sucesos
ocurridos el 7 de diciembre cuando
dispuso la disolución del Congreso el
juez César San Martín de la sala penal
permanente de la Corte Suprema declaró
infundado el recurso de apelación
Interpuesto por el abogado de Castillo
Eso quiere decir que el ex mandatario
tendrá que cumplir
en la cárcel de barbadío donde también
cumple condena el expresidente Alberto
fujimori la situación de Pedro Castillo
se complica la subcomisión de
acusaciones constitucionales del
parlamento también aprobó el informe que
recomienda acusarlo constitucionalmente
por los delitos de organización criminal
tráfico de influencias y colusión el
reporte será derivado a la comisión
permanente y si es respaldado será
enviado al pleno del Congreso y una vez
conseguida la aprobación la fiscalía
podrá impulsar un proceso judicial
contra Pedro Castillo el ex mandatario
ha rechazado las acusaciones y asegura
ser víctima de política pero las pruebas
aportadas por testigos lo contradicen
un total de 80 ciudadanos de Guatemala
fueron deportados en aviones este jueves
desde Estados Unidos al país
centroamericano se trata del último de
los 368 vuelos que Durante este año
sirvieron de vehículo para deportar un
total de
40.633 personas desde la Unión Americana
según las autoridades este año el número
de guatemaltecos deportados creció en un
128% respecto a 2021 se calcula que en
torno a 3 millones de ciudadanos de este
país viven en Estados Unidos la mayoría
de forma irregular provenientes de un
país azotado por la pobreza y la
violencia
un poco triste porque
tenemos un sueño de ir a sacar para
adelante la familia Pero
mira que nos pasamos nos nos agarraron
en la frontera ahí en roselin Texas y
ahorita nos tuvimos cinco o cinco días
preso
encerrados y ahorita aquí estamos en
Guatemala en el aeropuerto y todo eso y
nos deportaron
cerramos en Nueva York que es donde se
abrió el primer dispensario legal de
marihuana más de un año después de que
el estado legalizara esta droga el
comercio fue abierto por housing works
una organización sin ánimo de lucro que
lucha en favor de los sintecho y contra
el sida que obtuvo una de las primeras
36 licencias para dispensar Marihuana el
mes pasado esto en medio de los retrasos
para abrir el mercado legal que permita
beneficiar a personas detenidas
previamente por delitos relacionados con
la marihuana
para nosotros la legalización nunca se
ha tratado simplemente de liberar la
planta te conocí temprano la
interseccionalidad de este tema la forma
en que podríamos usar esta lucha para
Elevar otra luchas otras voces y no solo
una reforma significativa de la justicia
penal el acceso a la salud ya que todos
ustedes impulsan esas conversaciones
pero también asegurándonos de que
estamos creando oportunidades de una
nueva manera que estamos priorizando
reparando daños daños que han sido
causados incluso por las propias
políticas del Estado
hasta aquí las noticias sigan conectados
a France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]